once you've said a lot sure if you want
to go to most or most or all then no but
uh there's certainly there certainly
people there's a great quote by the
physicist what's-his-name wine Weinberg
I don't know I hate getting yes ever it
is Steve Lambert the quote of with or
without religion good people will do
good things and bad people do bad things
but for good people to do bad things
that takes religion I'm not sure that's
word-for-word almost certain it isn't
but it's important um I think it's not
religion it's it's much deeper than that
my beef is not with religion per se my
difference of opinion is with objective
and subjective reality
Einstein said you know the big question
is when you turn away is the tree still
there and you can I talk to Richard
Fineman about this in very go man
there's a feeling that in particle
physics the experimenter affect a lot of
that stuff is distorted I believe very
strongly that there is a physical
reality that my perception does not
change now you can make the argument
that we're all just brains in jars the
matrix and that all of this is an
illusion and that is an airtight
argument you can't you can't refute it
but let's just say it's not that I think
there's a real reality out there and the
people who say I believe in God because
I feel that there's some higher power in
the universe the problem I have with
that is that once you've said you
believe something that you can't prove
to someone else you have completely
walled yourself off from the world and
you've essentially said no one can talk
to you and you can talk to no one you've
also given license to everybody else who
feels that if you say to me I can't
prove it pen but I have a feeling
my heart that there isn't power over
everything that connects us
why can't Charlie Manson say I can't
prove it but I have a feeling that the
Beatles are telling us to kill Sharon
Tate and that the race riots are coming
why can't al Qaeda say I have a feeling
in my heart that we need to kill these
particular infidels oh why can't the men
who tortured and disfigured beyond here
see Ali why isn't what they feel in
their heart valid the problem is if you
have a sense of fairness simply by
saying you believe in a higher power
because you believe in it you've
automatically given license to anyone
else that wants to say that so I would
rather be busted on everything I say and
I am you know when you when you put
yourself out on television and on on
radio as someone who really does believe
an objective truth there is not a
sentence that I will say in this
interview that won't get three or four
tweets of somebody with information
busting me on it and they're right you
know very rarely am i busted on
something we're all right you know if
someone's taking the trouble to let me
know I've said something wrong
chances are I'm wrong
so but that's the world I want to live
in I want to live a world of a
marketplace of ideas where everybody is
busted on their all the time
because I think that's the way we get to
truth that is also what respect is what
we call tolerance nowadays maybe always
I'm always skeptical of the nowadays
thing I don't think things get get that
much different um what we call tolerance
is often just condescending it's often
just saying okay you you believe what
you want to believe that's fine with me
I think true respect is one of the
reasons I get along so much better with
fundamentalist Christians
that I do with with liberal Christians
because fundamentalist Christians I can
look them in the eye and say you are
wrong they also know that I will always
fight for their right to say that and I
will I will celebrate their right to say
that but I will look them in the eye and
say you're wrong and fundamentalist will
look me in the eye and say you're wrong
and that to me is respect the more
liberal religious people who go there
are many paths to truth you just go on
and maybe you'll find your way is the
way you talk to a child and I and I
bristle at that so I do very well with
proselytizing hardcore fundamentalists
and at a very deep level I respect them
and at a very deep level I think I I I
share a big part of their heart I think
in a certain sense I'm the preacher my
heart my heart is there